[Applause]
today we've invited members of the
public like yourselves out here to try
out the new Nintendo switch that's why
you absolute beauties if you know where
we are we're in a bar and absolutely
beautiful by here look at these absolute
beautiful bar star people here we're in
a bar so if you know where we are
head down if you don't sorry everyone
else here is going to enjoy Hey
so let's take out the first game now to
test that the Nintendo switch what we
did is we got members of the public
pressure of the audience and handed them
one of these absolute beautiful game
consoles and they're out here playing so
let's check out the first game the first
game we've got here is is the big eat
the big eating contest
how you guys doing actually harder than
it looks
but who knew the heat he can eat like
ten sandwiches are you serious yeah yeah
12:10 a half that's Mario that's
Margaret it's a record yeah I think
you've got record so far today nuts
let's see how you do well the right joke
on the iron version camera close to you
now hold that position three two one
come on come on keep going come on can
you can you be that hope to the nation
on the game in Bible public believe in
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
maybe like massage before you play it's
definitely worth it what a day today no
to come into that sense have a beer I'm
gonna say you are now baby
listen hey with the baby
one of the 28 games on the one to switch
console oh so how does this one work so
you get a baby and you have to rock it
to sleep and you have to be gentle and
nice and then you put it down in its
crib and it's kind of bad
we're not drinks a lot you know doing so
well no any kids yet no on evidence of
how you're doing in this game do you
think you think it should wait a while I
think he could be a dad soon look at
that down to a tee I know what you guys
up to today anyway we're actually just
visiting shopping etc and then you found
out there was free booze and and and and
banner pretty much Spring Break right
pretty much spring break Spring Break
with Nintendo frickin love it let's move
it on ah that's it got off on gosh
they're sort listen to whirl whirl whirl
whirl whirl what we doing nothing what
about the props guys come on all right
you've got one free hand yes I'm saying
on God
get them what yes get them get them mask
of zorro popping off so what's your
name's Adam Adam Chris I'm telling you
the game in public the gaming world
wishes it could be here right now you
know that beer games
all right guys look each other in the
eye come on come on all right with two
laps apiece don't worry about this or
you still going Oh
keep it moving
come on come on oh I see the red flag of
victory the red flag of victory what
happened there I was too busy concerned
about these crops
I lost the focus on the game I've been
safety health and safety hey hey excuses
excuses me champion I mean yeah I've
lost past 20 so this is quite a nice
feeling to win one he just can't handle
the camera you can't handle all the
pressure
are you from today we do I meant to be
in work today but I called in sick so
this is Saturday so I mean nothing
yeah I went to the doctor and it's not
good so I mean this is my yeah this is
your yeah rehabilitation yeah this is
this is what he recommended me to get
well mindfulness and all that stuff you
know so all right next we're moving on
to you and dance-off yeah
fantastic well you know ready I should
play I'm gonna play laughter see you
looks moves I mean I see you guys
already been sweating out it's hot and
sweaty dancing where you love with you
baby that's come from Chicago Chicago
and break dancing let's get some
practice all right let's get it going
okay oh you've got fries as well yeah
it's kind of like it's a bit like hey
listen I think I'm I won this I'm sorry
I think I'm out I blame you
how you find a Nintendo switch today we
love it it's portable it's fun I want to
take it home with us really big well
good good fingers and sell in the United
States as well so thank you so much
we're gonna take a look upstairs
at the next games let's go let's do it
man you've got so much more games going
on upstairs it's freakin insane can you
imagine like we are out here in Camden
North West London straight up chilling
afternoon and uh drinking beer playing
games ah my days full on workout coming
up these were hey would you look at that
I'm back in action ah
absolutely beautiful people up here
fantastic how're we doing up here good
time we've been drinking we play games
that's what I'm talking about what we
got here
all right let's get this game going all
right shake that soda when you pops
you lose real don't pop that soda that
soda let's go look at this hand pushing
ah what quality prefer listen I've done
this before
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
that time so guys you guys are just
tuning in there's no way you think we're
actually playing the one two switch
absolutely beautiful shoulder shake game
hey how're you finding this afternoon to
be here doing so great time today isn't
it beer in your head there's somebody's
to shake this check this map yeah this
business one more time in Camden on a
lovely day shaking the so drop of what
my best ones I got my best on this you
again I see what you tried to do there I
see what you guys see where you try to
the one she are moving over to quick
draw I listen to be honest with you it's
got to be probably one of my favorite
games on the switch had it up this is
going to be absolutely intense you might
want to might want to have a gun in your
other hand
listen don't fire the wrong hand you
know did we fire the wrong hand yeah I
mean yeah I mean this is dangerous I'm
gonna I'm gonna take this I'll be the
sheriff I owe them but you got what you
put the N but you're someone shot early
put trigger trigger think come on
trigger there's a straight-up party Pat
you got it you got it all right Keith
yeah all right look each other in the
eye but camicazi action that was
incredible incredible well enjoy
yourselves
thank you all right these guys over here
are playing gorilla are you guys are you
guys finding it it's all right it's all
right now but we're gonna get it on the
big screen let's make this movie from
tabletop mode and let's bring it to TV
MA
yeah three controllers with you yet
Detroit once renamed Jenkins I'm sorry
you absolute babies we're gonna we're
gonna switch
so the shakers Solar shakers you can
take this over to the table and we are
going to pop this in ah we can look at
that and back in we're back carried over
twice oh we don't we ain't gonna count
that one this is this is where it counts
this is where it matters live in their
religion instead of dough and Oh Aaron J
Darren in J alright so basically what
are you gonna do in this game we got
after your gorilla gorilla be a girl be
I'm loving the shades on the inside
there buddy was looking at me in the
eyes
[Laughter]
ready if you look me in the eye
you go beginning medium to the beat
[Laughter]
that's know in the comments below
champion Oh Darrin come on Darrin hey
you absolute gorilla me watch everybody
going on now Spencer what's happening
downstairs you guys enjoy yourselves J
track track track the weather of course
J what you need to do is concentrate on
trying to move hey listen we're gonna
head downstairs right now oh man it's
going on downstairs been a minute since
I've been down here come on
[Music]
we are back alright we are going to head
over to the artisan Table Tennis this
can get real this game can get real
intense listen you guys don't understand
here we've got one of these in the lab
Babel office it gets real competitive
tips to snow to snow
where you guys come from today from
where messaging Boston Massachusetts
okay okay you know she got you in a
quick listen listen everything goes you
know you always gotta be ready always
got to be ready it's not happening for
you today is it happening right now is
it a little sweet of the final games of
the games real quick we've got dots
going on how you guys doing worse all
right good listen to me I bought him so
you know all right get the wizard out
you're a wizard Harry
what's going on well I'm trying to be
Harry Potter I just beat her just before
this I swear was it was it was it TV
pressure I was never I never tried to be
the mother I was just the nanny on the
side okay okay okay
like the helping with the rhythm making
sure the babe was on the baby all that
and if it was your own kids he would
have had that down to a tee
what's the favor game so far what's been
your favorite one the eating one because
I just think it's so great because you
just like yeah no I loved it when you
were doing it because you had so much
enthusiasm so much noise yeah you have
to actually pretend you're eating a real
sandwich you have to pretend you're
eating a real sandwich love it love it
in fact we're gonna head to that one
right now so are you here someone's
about to kick-start don't look at me
sandwich we're getting around six I
think with you here I got a let's see
let's have one more round the final game
of the evening see what I'm saying
oh there's no way oh this could be a
record hold on what every guy likes it
to me listen hey guys we are gonna be
here for the next couple of hours just
playing drinking the bar still open the
free bar still on
I can't drink on cam so I'm going that
you guys go and get some beers in the
beer there banner it's going to continue
everyone's having a good time playing
out the nintendo's or a huge amount of
thanks to Nintendo for the Nintendo
switch you freaking love you and I'm out
of it
my name is cheeky school Dave this has
been the gaming babble and we're out
come on
[Laughter]